ça fait maintenant huit ans que la
célèbre émission de l'île de la
tentation a disparu de la télévision
française
alors pour ceux qui ne se souviennent
plus de cette émission mois voilà gens
ne ratez pas une ça c'est raymond
démission de raymond s'est étonné le
connaît oui c'est arrivé jusqu'à nous un
bien sûr puis 64 ont donc l'île de la
tentation je sais ce que c'est j'adore à
chaque fois du bon il adore quand il est
moins bien entendu eh bien regardez vous
êtes un petit point alors là vous allez
vous régaler avec cette vidéo récap de
l'île de la tentation et vous me lirez
dans un instant si pour vous êtes énervé
ou 1 depuis tout à l'heure il est énervé
celui-là il est chafouin fait parce
qu'il a eu ce matin c'est pas pour les
téléspectateurs des années 2000
impossible de passer à côté de l'île de
la tentation émission culte de tf1 qui a
marqué l'histoire de la télé réalité le
concept plusieurs couples participer à
l'émission pour tester la solidité de
leurs relations alors arrivés il était
séparé les hommes sur une île les femmes
sur une autre chaque groupe en compagnie
de tentateurs et de tentatrice dont
l'unique mission était de les faire
craquer et bonne nouvelle pour les fans
de l'émission elle s'apprête à faire son
grand retour
comme l'indiquent ce message posté par
une productrice de la société banide g
sur les réseaux sociaux
vous avez envie de vivre une expérience
unique pour vous prouver votre amour et
renforcez votre couple envoyez nous vos
coordonnées à l'heure actuelle on ne
sait pas sur quelle chaîne ce remake
sera diffusée mais on espère y retrouver
des séquences aussi culte que dans la
première version hors de lui brandon
c'est armé d'un bâton et devient
totalement incontrôlable reste à savoir
si cette nouvelle version comportera des
nouveautés comme dans la version
italienne où les tentateurs sont à la
recherche de l'amour
eh eh oui ça va revenir alors on a des
infos sur l'île de la tentation donc ça
va revenir
apparemment les missions à faire son
grand retour prochainement sur w9
voilà et se pourrait que l'émission ne
soit plus diffusée en seconde partie de
soirée comme à l'époque mme en prime
time bien entendu parce que qu'est ce
qui la maintient coûte cher juli et donc
et gilles verdez vous avez un point et
je vous dirais la fin de ce jeu pourquoi
conques les ponts et vous allez voir
juste ça va vous faire tout drôle alors
autour de l'île de la tentation est ce
que vous vous hip hop vous allez
regarder ou pas c'est un des rares
émissions qui avait été arrêté en plein
de succès c'est vrai elle passe avec 40%
par les marchés cette gigantesque ou
moins cette émission on sait seront bien
gardées non c'est pas hypocrite non moi
j'ai reçu c'est pas hypocrite c'est
typiquement mis en scène mais on sait où
on va et on sait ce qu'on va voir donc
j'aime beaucoup c'est matthew n'êtes pas
d'accord avec le petit c'est la pire
émission je pense vraiment des canards
année il ya peu d myriam ou fois en
termes d'éthique ya 15 jan prennent
dizaine d'années il était venu il aller
dans les salles de sport il était venu
pour me castet en tentateur nom et alary
venait et vous vous disais est ce que
voilà c'est important c'est l'amour est
ce que vous pourriez testé pour être sûr
qu'un couple s'entende bien qu'ils
soient heureux il vous vend des sacs à
main joli truc alors que si c'est
franchement ce qu'il ya de pire je pense
dans les émissions en réalité mais
vraiment l'effet laquelle ont été
arrêtés justement parce que les études
étaient désastreux sur tf1 - il voulait
changer d'image c'est bouillot qui anime
et ça je me souviens on était vraiment
fan pour moi c'est c'est lui je faisais
alors ça fait jamais vous
[Rires]
et en effet je vois ma meuf en train de
se faire pénétrer par jour
je connais la fin merci c'est bon ça
c'est vrai que moi j'adorais y avez vous
vu et à la fin ils leur poser la
question est-ce que vous reparler
ensemble séparément on aurait dit la vie
de benjamin castaldi n'a démarré il ya
ya bien sûr une vidéo mythique c'est
brandon et oui oui et vous vouliez dire
un truc elena moi ce que je disais c'est
que c'est une des dernières années où la
téléréalité l'été et n'était pas aussi
fait que maintenant qu'on leur demande
c'est qu'ils reprennent pas des
candidats qu'on connaît déjà qu'ils
prennent des inconnus et qui soit - rôdé
que les autres pour qu'on retrouve
l'authenticité naturel mission et jack
london vous savez vous rappelez du bâton
et ça c'est mythique de lautier et
l'autre on dirait qu'il parle d'un livre
extraordinaire c'est le grand bol sous
le choc des images
brandon enfreint toutes les règles de
l'émission et ses chats cour rejoignent
palmetto le site des femmes
hors de lui brandon c'est armé d'un
bâton et devient totalement
incontrôlable on entend résonner un
terrien ce débat va pas faire de grâce
au dvd tf1 arrêté l'émission la chaîne
voulait moraliser son antenne oui j'ai
le décès de la récupérer mais c'est la
plus sulfureuse des émissions et pour ça
qu'on aime le plus qui croire
est ce que vous y croyez vous sûr que
les spectateurs qui nous regarder en
direct sur ces huit noms et bien j'y
crois pas soit c'est moi qui croyais à
[ __ ] cette émission était mortel tu
voyais des mecs qui arrivent et avec des
tablettes de chocolat des bonnes me
faisais moi j'ai confiance ça peut aller
sur l'île au bout de deux jours le mec
qui pleureuse qu'est-ce que vous avez
saisies alors voulez que je vous dise
à chaque fois moi je me disais est ce
que ma meuf est ce que si elle va sur
lui même la tentation est ce qu'elle se
fait plus aucun nom c'est beaucoup de
questions parce que tu imagines tu es
tranquille sur l'île toi yatama fait
quand même partie grâce à toi tu te fais
non mais tu vas beaucoup manqué tout
sortira de cette île se mariera et donc
et après je te jure
2' rappeler et la meuf elle a posé ses
valises frère elle est un humain avec
des cas moi
là bas on est bon mais le mec qui veut
faire et a duré en tout cas revenir
je pense que nous en tout cas on va se
régaler en syrie s'est revus en version
low cost parce que toutes ces émissions
coûter entre 15 et 20 millions d'euros
ou pensez bien que la tnt peut pas se
fermer mais ouais mais ça revient moyen
comparé à l'île de la tentation a
peut-être offert lille à lille totalise
arrive aujourd'hui avec les bacs écrivez
vous avez déjà vu ça vous descend pas
contre non mais pour le moment je vois
des zodiaques elle des pêcheurs moi je
suis un no mercy j'ai pas de boisson au
durcissement
on vous a jamais demandé
d'ailleurs les filles qui sont là vous
êtes jamais demandé d'être tentatrice
bell fibe six mois la semaine dernière
j'ai reçu une proposition de casting
pour être tentatrice d'un nouveau jeu
l'année dernière sur la tnt
ah ouais et vous n'ont jamais battu sûr
que c'est ça ben on attendait dans les
pubs ou quoi tu imagines tu vois daniel
arriver
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]